i'm nicole and i'm ben and we're
linguists and today we're going to tell
you about some things you might not have
known about how language lives when it
comes to the casual and playful language
we call slang words can get popular
really quickly among certain groups and
can disappear just as quickly slang is
often a kind of in-group marker so if
some slang term gets too popular too
quickly outside of that in-group that
can spell the end of its usefulness so
with youth slang for instance if the
olds start using it then you know it's
no longer youth slang let's take a look
at house lane can bubble up disappear
and sometimes even come back
nicole i have a pop quiz for you let's
imagine that you could time travel and
you could go back to the year 1699 and
let's say you could go to the streets of
london and hear people talking
let's say you also wanted to insult
someone's intelligence which of these
words could you not use as an insult at
the time
booberkin
cladpate
dull pickle nick manog
or jabber knoll if i'm thinking about
the etymology then like
there's like nog which might be like
noggin like brain
maybe the one that's not is jabernal
well i'm sorry this is actually a trick
question all five of these wacky words
could be used at the time in 1699 to
refer to a dim-witted person a blockhead
a numbskull and we know this because in
that year of 1699 there was a dictionary
published and it's one of the first ever
slang dictionaries for english this was
a dictionary of kant which is the
special secret language used by thieves
and pickpockets and other low-life
characters
maybe they were making fun of each other
maybe they were making fun of the marks
then you know whose pocket they were
going to pick maybe we should revive
some of those words i'd love to call
somebody a dull pickle or a jabber knoll
you know i bet those thieves in london
weren't too happy that somebody came
along and made a dictionary with all of
their secret language in it yeah because
then they had to come up with a whole
new set of words for insulting people
right so from the earliest recorded
slang in english one thing we see is
that these words can have a really short
shelf life just from
too many people knowing about it
the whole process of slang becoming
popular and then immediately passe gets
accelerated when you can spread new
language around really quickly so if
you're on social media you might see a
lot of slingy flashes in the pan you
remember
back in let's say late 2011 early 2012
do you remember yolo
oh yeah that acronym for you only live
once which i think we have drake to
thank for that uh in his song the motto
you only live once that's the model
you know i wrote something about yolo in
the summer of 2012 and i remember it was
already getting played out and it was
just you know months after the song came
out but then i really knew that it was
over for yolo when i heard that katie
couric on her new talk show was doing a
segment called what's your yolo where
you were supposed to come on and talk
about things you want to do before you
die my yolo would really surprise you
yeah that was an actual clip from the
segment so
when that happens you know that yolo is
over that was really the death knell for
it katie kirk on your talk show is not
exactly the epitome of cool
but yolo did have a good run before it
became way too cringe now that process
can happen even faster let's look at
chugi uh do we have to it's a good case
study of how slang gets played out these
days chugi kind of came out of nowhere a
young woman named gaby rasin claims that
she invented it in 2013 but we don't see
it in urban dictionary until 2018.
people still didn't really notice it
until an april 2021 piece by taylor
lorenz in the new york times where she
writes all about chugi talk about
overexposure a piece in the new york
times i think that could really kill a
new slang term and that's pretty much
what happened lorenzo's piece ushered in
the chugification of chugi itself chugi
was a way for gen zirs to talk about how
millennials were off trend but once
millennials like taylor lorenz herself
were using it then it was already chugi
itself the word chugi is now itself
actually
got it
a couple of years after the heyday of
yolo came on fleek yeah on flick that's
an interesting one because much like
chugi we actually know who came up with
it i mean usually with new slang terms
we can't really pin down who coined it
but in this case we can say that yeah a
17 year old from chicago named kayla
newman using the handle peaches monroe
posted a video of herself on vine in
june 2014. abras on fleek
r.i.p vine i loved those short little
videos they were awesome in the vine
kayla described her eyebrows as on fleek
before going out to a party and
basically meaning that they were
perfectly done or flawless kayla's
perfect eyebrows made such an impression
that soon celebrities like ariana grande
were posting their own on fleek vines
even kim kardashian got in on the action
and eventually it made its way to brands
like ihop started using on fleek brands
why do they have to ruin everything yeah
and it's not the first or last time that
a young black woman came up with a
linguistic innovation that everybody
else latched on to
there are cases where a slang term
can just keep going and have the same
kind of playful and irreverent air to it
think about booze sometimes i do
well the word booze goes back to
16th century or so and we find it in
glossaries of criminal jargon there's a
book from the 1530s that actually
defines it as alcohol or drink and it
could also be a verb meaning to drink
and it came from this older dutch word
poison meaning to drink to excess so
here we are five centuries later and
we're still using that word booze in
pretty much the same way another pretty
sturdy slang word is cool and that one's
been hanging on for almost a century
yeah so the word cool has lots of
different meanings not just about
temperature so you could call a person
cool calm and collected for instance
starting in the 30s and especially the
40s cool developed this new sense and
that meant first rate excellent yeah i
think of cool as a jazzy word like the
miles davis album birth of the cool not
surprisingly jazz musicians have played
a big role in the popularization of the
word cool lester young prez young in the
early 1940s he loved using that word
cool his fellow musicians just picked up
on that we start seeing it in print in
1948 actually the new yorker and then of
course the teeny boppers got to it in
the 1950s right cool starts showing up
on lists of teen slang in 1952. then
before you know it it's in songs and
movies and all sorts of things
cool
really cool was there backlash against
cool after that yeah there was some
backlash the word cool wasn't so cool in
the 60s you could call things far out
and groovy and that sort of thing cool
kind of recedes a little bit but then it
comes right back in the 1970s and it
actually goes along with the whole kind
of 50s nostalgia you think about happy
days in greece and that sort of thing
since then though cool has stayed pretty
cool there's a linguist named donna joe
napoli who says it's held on because of
its underspecified nature that means it
can adapt to lots of different contexts
yeah and adaptability is key for words
to survive it doesn't seem like cool is
cooling off anytime soon but this is
another interesting point about who's
licensed to use which slang words the
nuances of meaning and what they say
about the speaker are also always
evolving and we've seen just from the
words that we've talked about whether
it's the dull pickles of 1699 or slang
terms that spread on social media in the
21st century who's using these words
when it's considered acceptable or cool
to use these words depends on a lot of
different social factors and whether
these words stay in the language or not
it just depends on what's cool and
what's not cool
yeah i mean we've talked about a lot of
words old and new we hope that you've
learned something too and we've got lots
more words to talk about so thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]